Mike The Situation is totally oh yeah I
think for like 8 nine years now that's
awes that's awesome which is crazy cuz
he was so bad like I've always been like
drinking but I've always been scared to
do drugs like I'm not like that thank
God can you imagine so Mike was like
really bad you know with the pills and
everything and it just changed him to be
a totally different person he's got two
kids sober for so many years killing it
with his businesses and of course DJ
pully he's the richest out of all of us
I bet huh he's getting all these
residencies Vegas he travels all around
the world like traveling every single
day crushing it how about that didn't he
sign with 50 yeah he went on tour
Britney Spears was like what is
happening it's crazy yeah it's super
crazy